navigation apps like Waze and Google
Maps can help speed up your commute but
they can make secret shortcuts very
public in communities like Leonia New
Jersey that's a small town just outside
of New York City quiet side streets once
used as shortcuts for savvy drivers are
now filled with bumper-to-bumper traffic
Jim Axelrod shows us the town's simple
new solution to cut down on all that
congestion Jim good morning hello good
morning the town of Ionia may only have
9,000 residents but its proximity to the
George Washington Bridge makes it
susceptible to intense traffic commuters
seeking shortcuts are using navigation
apps that funneled traffic through
residential neighborhoods but now the
town is fighting back this will change
life in Leoni it should this new sign in
Leonia New Jersey is a low-tech solution
to a high-tech problem there's
approximately 60 streets that are be
gonna be closed the one square mile town
lies in the shadow of the George
Washington Bridge a small town with a
big problem for years whenever traffic
would back up at the bridge savvy
commuters would get off the highway and
take a shortcut through Leonia if you
knew the secret stay to the right to
exit 78th Leonia you could beat the jam
but now navigation apps like Waze and
Google Maps are sending commuters
through side streets turning this quaint
residential area into a parking lot
mayor Judith Ziegler you're driving on
streets that we're quiet residential
streets it's why people live here and
literally their bumper to bumper to
bumper to bumper traffic residents like
Melissa's sosman are fed up how long
does it take you to get out easily take
10 minutes 15 minutes it depends on
who's gonna be nice and how much I'm
gonna push up against their car til they
let me out the town's plan is to
restrict access to around 60 side street
entrances during rush hour by using
these new street signs Leonia residents
and businesses will be given this yellow
hang tag for street access and if you
don't have one you risk getting a ticket
we're not talking about 20 bucks
now we're talking about $200 200 bucks
has some teeth
once the law takes effect on January
22nd apps like Waze will remove side
streets from its shortcuts menu but
they're gonna start pulling them out
systemically we are also proactively
reaching out to them and saying hey
guess what our law has changed these
streets no longer viable options during
these hours etc town officials say it's
all legal
last month Leonia voted unanimously to
pass the ordinance for years if there
was a backup at the GW there were ways
to get to the gwe yes but it was word of
mouth yes
now there's ways now there's ways that's
the game changer
police chief tomorrow the traffic
navigation apps are the modern-day Pied
Piper and that's there's no question
about that my mind people will do
whatever the app tells them to do it but
row stress is the new law isn't all
about preventing traffic jams when we
have this traffic where motorists have
no concern for pedestrians they want to
get to their end destination as quick as
possible speed limits be damned and for
those we own your residents who just
want to get around town the new law
can't come soon enough
so this is a good is a good idea thank
you it's a great idea mayor Ziegler says
the new law won't prevent commuters from
going through Leone they can still use
the town's mains roads in a statement of
CBS News Wei says Waze maps are
regularly updated to reflect both local
law and changing road conditions in
order to give our users the best driving
experience this includes road closures
but the towns have to implement the
ordinance before the app companies will
sort of stop sending them out into the
neighborhoods
I felt like Waze has gotten less
brilliant than it originally was yeah
it's not getting me to those secret side
streets nobody knows about because
everybody knows about it doesn't want
them sitting in the marriage really
looking out for citizens for him yep the
secret streets of Lyon
favourite book Jim thanks for watching
we'll be right back